today's guest is uh is a
real dominant and uh
and hilarious and just dang near
adorable
female that's right
female baby you know what i'm talking
about boobies uvula baby all of it
and uh she is from atlanta and um
and i'm just so happy to finally be able
to sit down with her
uh ladies and gentlemen the one and only
heather
[Music]
mcmahon
[Applause]
me
she likes a hard seat it's fine she's
got a crippling sciatica
so it's fine oh yeah a lot of my friend
has an australian shepherd and it has
dysplasia
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah most of them do i
think
yeah i got a frenchie and they have
every [ __ ] problem do they yeah
i like needed that expensive [ __ ] up
dog yeah that's where we're at you know
a lot of i think frenchies let me think
frenchies
australian shepherds i don't want to say
a lot of foreign dogs but
but it is what it is they can't handle a
lot of you know they can't handle that
american pressure
that's really i think the fact is once
you get you know even you get those shih
tzus and they got them all pilled up
i don't [ __ ] with the [ __ ] i don't [ __ ]
with the shih tzu yeah do not [ __ ] with
the shih tzu
and let me tell you this i tried to do
the right thing i went to like eight
different french bulldog rescues i was
like i want one spina bifida
one in a wheelchair yeah one leg no leg
no nose
one who knows where there's treasure
yeah yeah exactly and i got denied all
the [ __ ] time because i was living in
new york and they're like oh your
apartment's not big enough i actually
had a very nice apartment for new york
and so we kept getting denied and so my
husband was like [ __ ] this he's like
after we got denied like the seventh
time he's like we would be perfect
parents we were like let's get the most
expensive purebred
we were just like let's get find the
breeder who's got like just wears gold
all the time yeah and that's the way we
would napoleon
i want one fresh out of napoleon's nut
sack that's how friends exactly
i want this thing to be man yeah yeah i
think it's tough i've been thinking
about trying to get a dog and so i've
been thinking about like
what kind of get like i think about yeah
how pure can they get
how pure can the breeding get yeah you
know what i'm saying i want that [ __ ]
i want that thing afraid to show up to
war that's how french i wanted yeah yeah
i feel like i am like
you wanted pure but you also wanted a
little [ __ ] though too oh really yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah i guess i could see maybe a
uh
i don't know if they had a lot of [ __ ]
dogs busts growing up i'm trying to
think of the dogs that i would see when
i was young
well we used to bet like if a dog was
giving birth people would go out and bet
on it and bet how many babies it was
going to have
this is so louisiana so if a dog was
whelping they call it whelping i think
then they would people would be out
there throwing a little bit of money
down oh hell yeah you know and trying to
win a little or just trying to you know
just i guess maybe just also just feel
what it's like to be victorious maybe
not even
it might not even have been about the
money i mean you know
i i feel like degenerate gambling is the
thing like my husband gambles a little
bit does he really and i don't get it
yeah it's fine but i don't get it like i
i won't even put ten dollars
on like a craps table like i just i'm
like no [ __ ] that i know how hard
and how long it took to make those ten
and i'm like making a little money now
but i'm still just like
there's no [ __ ] way i'm gambling no
do you give your husband a little bit of
an
of an allowance or does he have his own
uh does he have his own
no he has his own job yeah yeah he has a
job
yes i do not know oh yeah that's right
no he has a job
well actually technically right now he's
uh
he's i call him the house manager so he
gave up his career in new york we were
living there we moved back to atlanta
and i'm like listen until you build your
real estate [ __ ] here
like i need you to be the house manager
because we're redoing some [ __ ] are
y'all are yeah we are
yeah we're in like yeah okay so i'm
sitting here with heather mcmahon thanks
for coming in i know we've been trying
to
get to see each other for a long time i
know and uh
yeah i had so many people that were like
can i come over if heather's going to be
there
i had more women i'll tell you this i
had more women offer to come over
in the past five days since people knew
you were going to be here
than have ever wanted to come and spend
time with me those are my hoes i love
them shout out to all the girls out
there yeah i didn't get a good look at
them but i
some of them seem like hoes over text
and you know it's you know that's a good
thing
yeah if like if you present yourself a
little [ __ ] and you just
you know you're honest and transparent
about it like you do you yeah
you know the ball's in your court i'm
here for it yeah i like that
i um so you started out doing comedy in
atlanta
um or you didn't start out doing comedy
so you're like uh you're kind of one of
these hybrid people kind of
and i'm not judging i'm just trying to
say stuff and think at the same time
right no no i hear you um so you're like
one of these hybrid kind of
artists like tell take me into it a
little bit what is it
well so the first time i ever did stand
up it was actually at my high school
prom so i went to this like really
conservative christian school and they
always had like a
we couldn't even call it prom we had to
call like the junior senior senior
banquet just because it's like [ __ ] up
right and so they wanted like a surprise
guest and so i said they they approached
me i don't know why because it was like
highly inappropriate they said i did
and so the first time i did stand-up was
at this prom and i was
roasting the senior class and i was like
if i can get up in front of these
[ __ ]
peers that are like the most judgmental
people on the planet yeah and i just
came alive i was like this is what i
want to do forever and i was always a
theater nerd and was doing all that
so i went to ole miss got a theater
degree then went to new york and was
doing
kind of improv sketch like i really was
on the snl trajectory i was like that's
what i want to do
i love a wig i love a costume you know
that's just where i thrive that's where
i'm become
come alive yeah and i was out in l.a
doing ucb and was kind of doing that
underground scene and
and then you were really hustling it oh
i was
hustling raw dogging it whatever you had
to do i was doing it were you using sex
to try to get forward
you know what i i offered no one no one
picked up on it they were like we're
good
we're good yeah yeah yeah yeah like if i
could strip i would but i have eczema so
i feel like i would take off my clothes
and they'd be like we're good here's ten
dollars like
put your pants back on it's real rashy
yeah lotion night yeah
they should have lotion night at the
strip club for people with eczema
when does that start when do we start
getting strip nights
for when does the like cancel culture
like when does that like the diversity
force diversity culture hit the strip
clubs
when do we see like the girl doesn't
even climb up the pole it's like one of
those like
things at the uh hampton inn like
swimming pool that just
lifts you out of the water for the strip
club yeah it just takes her up the pole
slowly and then just bring her slowly
back down maybe that's a charity we
start
that's our philanthropy i like that yeah
yeah limp completely just limp strippers
so i have a uh
family member semi-family member who has
been an exotic dancer
oh yeah and in our town they had a um
strip club called kneels that's what it
was right and uh and i don't know if it
was supposed to be a strip club but
enough people were naked and they were
eventually you know what i'm saying you
could see some titty
i hear you so but the ceiling was low in
there
so the women would get on stage and
they'd have to duck and strip
so it was very like kind of occupational
hazard
i mean i would say yeah before they had
that yeah yeah yeah
this is just like yeah it was really
like uh
it had a lot of you know it was like the
scoliosis it was like
in the scoliosis belt right so there was
a lot of yeah but the women would have
to get
up there and so they'd have to strip so
it always had this very like
it looked like the women were sneaking
around you know what i'm saying because
they had to duck over a little bit with
a titty hanging out yeah yeah
yeah those are my girls so they had to
get into that um
i mean i'm from atlanta where like
stripping is an art form and i mean you
go to places like magic city and there's
like 15 girls on a pole like a jenga
set i mean it's insane and then you go
to places like the claremont lounge
which is very famous
yeah we're like you know the women are
in their 70s crushing beer cans with
their titties i mean it's just like
that's the the spectrum uh and so it
and then there's my favorite trick club
though swinging richards which is
mostly men and you just walk in and
literally it's just dudes doing the
helicopter just swinging their dick
around
really hell yeah yeah oh i've seen that
in germany at the park one time oh yeah
it seems very german yeah yeah i think
so the chopper the [ __ ] masculinity
uh-huh i remember somebody took me to a
gay club one time in baton rouge and i'd
never been i didn't know they had it
right right
so we walk in and there's like men with
no shirts on
and just jeans and i thought that the uh
air conditioner was broken
i didn't know what it was i was like
damn we're at a bar and this [ __ ] air
conditioner is
you know saying they should do something
because it seems crazy they got a decent
clientele for [ __ ] having no ac
and then i realized it was gay men dude
and they start and gay men get extremely
aggressive i feel like
they seem like a straight man is in the
building because i have this feeling
that a straight man
like guys want to try to get a hot girl
but for gay men the hot girl
is a straight man i hear you well a lot
of the dancers at swing and richard's
club in atlanta are straight dudes oh
and they have a big gay clientele but a
lot of them are straight dudes because
you know
i mean my sister's a criminal defense
attorney so she's had a couple of his
clients and she's like no no that's mark
that's mark he said seven duis
but like he's a good guy and he's also
like hits on me all the time so
yeah interesting yeah so so
so so then you were in new york and then
you guys decided to move
to atlanta now did you kind of take a
were you like
saying i'm going to take a sabbatical
from kind of the
uh because if you were if you were doing
like second city and stuff like that
were you like i'm gonna like step away
from that were you starting to do your
own thing what was it
i went to new york and then i went out
to la for four or five years and i was
out there and i was like i'm doing the
commercials and all that [ __ ] and i
never i didn't take the traditional
route like i was more
ucb and and really like honing that
craft if you will as
obnoxious as that sounds so i wasn't in
the store i wasn't doing
you know um the traditional stand-up
route and then
i kind of had this like oh [ __ ] aha life
moment where my dad passed recently of
cancer
so i had to pick up my life and move
back home to atlanta this is in
2016. so i pick back up i'm like
i'm just gonna go for like six months
i'm gonna help my mom figure out what's
next all this [ __ ]
and it was crazy i kind of started
living my life through instagram and
just really blowing up instagram and
using it honestly cathartically just
like get [ __ ] off my chest and dry out
new material
and it just blew up and so then i was
able to like work in atlanta a little
bit
and then i was like this is insane i you
know i don't know it was a weird
blessing like it was the darkest time of
my life
but it was so cool to like be able to
get an audience from that
and um i just started like putting funny
[ __ ] up that brought me joy i didn't
give a [ __ ] about being in la
i didn't give a [ __ ] about being in new
york i wasn't trying to impress anybody
and that's when the best [ __ ] came out
yeah and then we went back to new york
and i was touring in 2019 and it's just
been a wild ride since
yeah but now i'm back in atlanta yeah
and so now so now you have um
so now you find most but now you're
going on tour right yeah
so now you have a show that's going to
be on stage yeah so what's the stage so
like like
i mean it's a it's a grab bag um you
know it's it's a long stand up set but i
also bring out wigs and and have videos
it's kind of a mixture of like what i do
on instagram and
my kind of i don't know brand of of
comedy is very much so storytelling and
it's you know about my life and but
here's the thing i really like people to
leave and they're like i don't know what
the [ __ ] just happened
not like performance already like weird
but i like people to like maybe cry at
one moment and they're like i don't know
what the [ __ ] these feelings are but
something's coming up and then i just
hit you you know what i mean and they're
like this was [ __ ] weird
and i was here for it and it was rowdy
oh i like it yeah yeah i like it yeah i
think
some one of my goals always was stand up
was like
i don't care if people remember like a
joke that i told but i want people to
remember
me somehow like because that's what i
feel like you go back to see like you go
back you get invested in a human or in a
feeling i don't know if i get invested
enough in like a
joke alone because anybody can write a
joke
right i feel like i want to get invested
in somebody you know that's what makes
me as a
consumer want to be involved with
somebody yeah i mean i remember the
shows where you leave and you're like i
don't really know what just happened or
like yeah you just leave with that
feeling or that warmth or maybe like
shame
i don't know what it is oh yeah but i
want you to get in your car
and just be like something happened yeah
you know and like think about it for a
while
i don't know i'm a pisces so i like to
just get in there yeah you know what i'm
saying
oh i'm a pisces yeah when's your
birthday march
1-9 okay i'm one five oh yeah
this makes so what does it mean what
does it mean take me into this because i
don't know anything about it like and if
people did know about it i always
thought they were like sorcery or
something
or people would call them you know
people would curse when i was young you
know
i hear you know if people showed up with
the libras or something you know
oh well i don't [ __ ] with the taurus
like i don't like hold a lot of weight
into it but most tauruses have been
pretty evil in my life so i rebuke in
the name of jesus like if i walk by a
taurus i'm like
no not today yeah oh i feel the negative
energy
oh um but pisces what are taurus sorry
just so don't forget
um end of april through beginning of may
oh yeah so it's coming up so tourist
season is coming up
yeah yeah just keep your butthole
clenched like shit's going to get wild
oh dang oh wow so it's tourist season
what do they do
uh they're just like usually cheaters
god i'm going to get so much hate for
this
they cheat oh i want to know more about
three tourists
yeah you see them at strip malls
t-mobiles um a lot of chilies
you know what i mean they're always
hanging out at a chili's bar dude i
remember making love to this girl that
worked at chili's and uh
she had oh my god she had
all these pictures of i remember going
over her place she lived at her parents
house they were out of town apparently
or she killed them i don't know where
they were okay
they might still be out of town it's
been about 17 years but she worked at
achilles and she had all these pictures
of like all the local firemen in her
house
i remember um yeah i never even thought
about that till just now i wonder what
happened to that
maybe the firemen like helped bury the
family they were in on it
there was yeah it just got a little like
some chicks have that
diy dateline it kind of [ __ ] they want
you know
yeah yeah a little like oxygen channel
snap moment
that energy yeah that's a tourist woman
right there yeah she might have been a
taurus okay anyway
so but pisces we're creative um and
we're creative we're sensitive and it
doesn't necessarily mean that like
you're a sensitive person where
you're just empathetic like you're able
to connect with people on their emotions
okay but we're also terrible with money
like that's the number one thing we
we're able to make a lot of money
because we are big thinkers
but like if i get a hundred dollars i'm
spending 99. you know what i'm saying oh
yeah yeah
so yeah i gotta have like a financial
advisor and account and an attorney just
to be like
sign off on [ __ ] you know what i mean i
need like a ballot i need
uh a limit on my credit card you do i do
i do oh wow
yeah and i don't know what it's like i
don't gamble but if i'm making money i
want everybody to have it like i'm like
do you need a job
you know and my friend's like no heather
i i'm a you know financial investor like
i don't need a job i'm like i just want
to give you money because i feel like
i don't know why yeah i feel that
sometimes i feel sometimes like i don't
yeah like
money's i don't know money's so weird
yeah it makes me uncomfortable it makes
me feel like
i have it but i need it right you know
yeah
yeah i need it but yeah it makes me
uncomfortable i don't like being
somebody that has money because i think
i always judge people that had money
like i was always like all these [ __ ]
rich people and [ __ ] like that and so
i think sometimes i'm like oh man i
don't want to have any money you know
like but then you also have to have
money if
you can't tell the rent guy hey you know
i'm just trying i've been nice to people
this month he doesn't care you know
that's not his name and i've had no
money and it sucked so bad like i've
worked
every hospitality job you can imagine oh
really oh yeah
did you do doordash um i never did
doordash but like i was in
worked at every restaurant i worked
every job in a restaurant and when
you're working in restaurants for like
10 years i mean it just
takes a part of your soul away that i
don't know if you can ever get back but
i do believe you know like in israel you
have to
um serve in the army you have to survive
yeah yeah yeah two years right i think
yeah i think in america
everybody should have to either be like
a valet
you know any sort of like work at a
hotel working a restaurant
yeah something yeah work at a perkins
jiffy lube be a hostess out of perkins
for at least a year
yeah and then you can go out into the
real world and like be an adult yeah
yeah i think that's true it would be
nice if they had some kind of like a
like a little tributary of occupational
tributary that brought you out into the
mainstream yeah
um yeah i'm trying to think of a job
that i had that i really
that really really stuck to me um
well i used to sell mexican food for a
living
in a restaurant or just like no in a
restaurant yeah
but it was crazy man they had uh the two
chefs
back there or these two black women
named april in may
and they did not like cooking mexican
food so sometimes we would have to
literally go tell the tables that uh we
the chefs okay didn't feel like making a
quesadilla today
so we would like you'd be literally
offering like french toast and [ __ ] at
five p.m right
you got vague over there and i was so
scared of them that i was like afraid of
the confrontation
and sometimes i would just lock myself
away uh
from some of that because i don't want
to be a part of it um
do you think we had a question that came
in right here for you let's bring up
this question right here from this
young lady right here hey y'all my name
is jessica from atlanta
and my question for heather is if you
could start in
the broadway with the rat king himself
what production would you guys star in
and what would your roles be
well i've always been told i have a lot
of friends on broadway because i come
from the theater world
i've always been told the only role i
could play on broadway is pumbaa
from the lion king i don't know why but
they're like that's the only role
because i bring up a poom before you
picture
yeah yeah because why go ahead i'm sorry
no i don't know why i don't know if it's
like them just being [ __ ] and being
like this is the best you can be or it's
because i have like a deep voice
uh but yeah i think god what could we be
in the line is that the lion king uh-huh
yeah my friend dodd loomis actually
works he does the lion king
if you ever wanted to be that i think
you are better looking
right yeah but they're always like no
you be pumbaa like you just have the
energy of pumbaa i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that
eyes and maybe some of the cheek
structure
and i mean that in a very be i would
definitely spend time with this animal
we could do sound of music you know the
sound of music oh
yeah but this sound like it kind of has
a little willy nelson in the beginning
the sound is people opening cans of tuna
at home yeah
100 just the ring doorbell over and over
again
yeah the sound is people reaching for
that latch under a
car hood yeah in like the 90s where
people were it didn't just pop up
automatically
and you have to then it comes up an inch
for you then you have to put your
young [ __ ] hands into a dirt
[ __ ] hot [ __ ] car yes and reach
for a [ __ ]
lat yeah ugh the sound is just like
women trying to like uh
get around in their like purse just
looking for keys and [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
god damn it did i leave my keys it's
just that recording over and over again
the sound yeah that's it yeah yeah just
over and over again like god damn it
daryl
[ __ ] you i i knew you forgot the keys
that's it and there's three checkbooks
in there but there's no checks it's just
that like carbon stuff in the other side
yeah do you still have a checkbook
uh i still have a couple checkpoints
this sound is um
one of us running back to the microwave
because
the popcorn's already like past the one
or two second mark between the pops and
so we know it's just burning
so the sound is just just running back
to the microwave yeah
it's the sound of the music yeah listen
i think we could
listen when broadway comes back i think
this is our moment
you know i'm trying to get an egot i
want a tony and i've realized like maybe
i just need to write my own musical and
i can't really sing anymore
got this deep voice and so i'm like
maybe we do we should actually probably
do like a like a straight man play
though
you know something dramatic something
where we're both nude but there's
nothing sexual about it it's just for
some reason
because i didn't feel like that's the
only way you want to tone oh i got a
little erectile function so don't even
have to be something sexual about it if
there was it would take a couple
episodes
so i'm just gonna let you know yeah
there you go and i got eczema so
you know what but we're winning tony's
it's called back to back it's our sex
life
god i'm freezing my eggs just both of us
facing the other way
just ask to ask well let's go back to
bat yeah let's go back to them
i mean we can assume that our butts are
touching but i think yeah just for like
yeah the ass to ass thing is just gonna
be that's gonna make me nervous
okay i feel you i respect that didn't
mean to push that on you
i apologize i really apologize well i
thought you were pisces i thought we
were
vibing but okay so note dissolve oh what
else will
be the sound of music that would be
that's such it was such a great question
so
what else yeah what other kind of show
could we be if it was a
we could do like hello dolly now i don't
know what you know about musicals but we
i mean hello dolly is like this very
iconic old show
it's southern is it southern no it's not
southern never mind
um but it's i mean we i could see you in
like a hoop skirt
having a moment you know with like a hat
on and like a like a pipe or something
okay yeah you're a little old-timey okay
okay okay i'm gonna go with this i
i think we could do like a i don't know
hello dolly but i've been a dollywood
once oh [ __ ] yeah
um so what about hello dollywood
i could play dolly parton yes we just
wrote this
so this is our pitch and broadway we
would like some fun
what is your dolly part and you just
park your hair like so severely
yeah and it's um no that's not a good
one um
yeah but you know that thing now is that
these young kids on tick tock are
telling women i'm 34 they're saying that
we can't do a side part anymore they're
like no it's only a middle part
we can't wear skinny jeans anymore it's
like this whole [ __ ] thing that these
young girls are trying to tell us
how to dictate our life and our
aesthetic and i'm [ __ ] pissed about
this have you heard about it
i haven't heard about that and i'm also
glad i haven't heard about that because
it seems like it's
it's emotion yeah yeah and it's okay i'm
glad that women are doing stuff but i
don't want to know about it you know
i guess i love that women are telling
other women what they're doing wrong
because that's feminism yeah that's what
we need we need more
right i think it should let's i want to
see it spill out into the streets i
would love to see here's what
here's where it is okay is a couple of
19 or seven-year-old women
getting abused by some
30 year old women there's a street fight
listen i went back to my story at ole
miss like before rush and they wanted me
to give like a motivational speech and i
literally no way really i scared you
were you the head of your sorority i
could see you being like the um
the lady at night that comes down it's
like only one peanut butter you know
who's that lady the house mom no she's
like a 65 year old lady who's living
rent-free
yeah yeah she's like no boys upstairs
but also only one peanut butter okay
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i remember that yeah that
later always like one peanut butter
you'd be like doing oral sex on some
woman and she's like one peanut butter
you're like oh damn because that's every
man's fantasy is that women in a
sorority house are just doing oral sex
on each other
that's it you guys just eat each other
out all day right it's like no
no i remember doing oral sex on some
woman uh-huh
and at ithaca college somewhere i don't
know
and some lady peeked in it was like only
one piano
i mean yeah no i ran my sorority i tried
to be president but because i wasn't
from mississippi
they were like it's not going to look
well across campus like it was a big
deal i mean i went to ole miss i like
ole miss was weird ole miss was weird
and it was amazing and it's
god when if i die like spread my ashes
in oxford
um but it was kind of a culture shock
for me like i didn't even know what the
capital of mississippi was i got there
and people were like oh we're from
jackson and they're like very
you know old southern money like we're
from jackson i'm likeville florida like
i don't know
what the [ __ ] mississippi is but it's
the greatest place on earth truly um
but yeah no i was i was a big day
president i was pledge class president
and then bid day so like
i would totally see that yeah yeah yeah
and i could say oh
well my best friend scott went there and
he was in
sigma
they've been kicked off campus i think
it was yeah yeah probably because of
scott
yeah i wouldn't be shocked man it was
either scott or it was probably i don't
remember
they had like south seas or something
was there
oh was that
did i have sex with scott i don't know
he'll i mean he'll i'll i'll ask him
later okay
but um he uh
he i remember going up there and yeah
everybody you'd have like the drunkest
somebody that couldn't even read me like
you know faulkner
uh oh it's always about father you have
no [ __ ] idea who fought nervously
used my mouthwash here and it'll be like
what who gives a [ __ ] like all of a
sudden everybody's into like early
american poetry
i didn't know who the [ __ ] yeah you know
they uh they uh excavated a cannon from
under this restaurant you know
it's like a lot of [ __ ] facts all the
time and you're like all right
mississippi pump the brakes a lot of
plaques
yeah uh-huh a lot way too many plaques a
ton of plaques
ton of cocaine yeah a lot of just plaid
like gingham
shepherd smith i heard shepherd smith
used to go do cocaine there do you ever
hear that story
yeah i'm pretty sure [ __ ] i don't want
to say that but yeah i'm pretty sure
like
yeah i mean whatever [ __ ] we all did
cocaine at ole miss so yeah if shepherd
smith came out of the closet he could
it's easy to come out of the club it's
way easier to come out of the cocaine
closet i think
than the actual closet i mean it was
just such another planet i got there
it's just like
you know you have all these like rich
kids from the south but it was weird
because i was in the
art department i felt like like i went
and visited alabama and i swear to god i
went to visit and i was like okay i only
have two choices because i didn't you
know my sats like
a blind cat could have done a better job
on that sats of me
even though i was student body president
of my high school i still there i
thought i was gonna go to pepperdine
like long story short i was like i'm
gonna go school in california oh wow
an artist all this [ __ ] they're like you
were 100 denied so it was two weeks
before graduation
they were like like who did this testing
and the funny thing is when the lori
laughlin thing came out where like you
know she was paying somebody to like get
her kids into college
my sister called me she's like dad my
sister wanted to attack she's very
intelligent and um
troy tech no georgia tech sorry yeah
troy tech
which is in alabama troy i think is uh
i'd never heard of troy tech i was even
like that is a reach troy state okay
troy state yeah there is troy state in
alabama shout out troy stevens
shout out troy um they got a good
wendy's enjoy do they that's it though
yeah i could see that but long story
short my sister's like you know dad was
so stressed out about the fact that you
did such a bad job on your sats that he
like called me and thought that
you know i was gonna go take your test
for you like he just was like so worried
that i wasn't gonna get into college
so it was either alabama or ole miss and
i visited alabama one weekend and this i
swear to god this is like so on the nose
but this guy named bubba
was in overalls at this like theta kai
house and he was just coked out of his
mind and it was like a chicken tender
eating contest which i love tindy's now
but at the time i was just like
and he was hitting on me and i was like
i gotta get out of alabama like i'm not
going to school here right so i just
like that's it i guess i'm going to ole
miss and i showed up at orientation was
like [ __ ] yeah
hottie toddy let's go and it was the
best four years of my life
and then i did cocaine with shepherd
smith so oh yeah okay good good good
i was wondering how it ended um
yeah josh kelly used to go there when
josh kelly uh
because he went to ole miss i remember
um
yeah i like i liked going to ole miss it
was just different i didn't grow up like
with any tradition or anything like that
so you went there and everything was
very it was everything was very
traditional
well it was a big deal you know i just
thought you wore like a t-shirt to a
football game they're like
you're showing up in pearls high heels
it's august it's 115 [ __ ] degrees out
the humidity's at 300 and you're just
melting and you're sweating out the
jaeger from the night before
but you're having to stand there with
like a shrimp cocktail platter and like
try and look regal and like
i'm a debutant but literally i'm just
oozing
gin and jaeger so um i learned a lot i
learned how to like
you know grab myself up by the
bootstraps and get my [ __ ] together yeah
oh i could
see that i feel like it is really it
is like a sephora boot camp yes for
women [ __ ] i totally see ole miss
being like that now because i would
remember yeah we'd go to some of these
parties and everybody
girls all the boys have names like
gryffindor the six and [ __ ] you know
two last names like sutton miller foster
yeah yeah it was all
way like insane like yeah you know his
daddy invented the swing set
you know like there was always [ __ ] that
was [ __ ] way crazy you know
they're like oh his great grandfather
admitted that news seemed like that's a
[ __ ] that's
i wouldn't lead with that i had an intro
at a party
let's just call let's just yeah but then
yarn
you know what i'm saying like it was
yarn and you guys did something you
shouldn't with it right
you know but then you had to buy cocaine
from him so you're like [ __ ] now i gotta
get into this conversation with
gryffindor
god damn it oh god it would just be
it made me feel i felt so foreign when i
would go to those places because
i think yeah i just never was into that
kind of culture and like that bro some
of that bro culture always kind of
spooked me a little bit i hear you
because you get guys that would be like
you know i'll do anything for this
right you know you know you get guys
drinking each other's blood and stuff
and like you know this this martini oh
this uh bloody mary has real blood in it
you know
this has two pints of my oh of my uh
pledge in it yeah that would happen at
the sae house they actually like some
party called patty murphy where they
just had to get this guy as drunk as
possible and i remember being there and
like
being 19 and just going i'm like i'm
like this isn't right
i was just like this seems unsafe and
then next year that that party got shut
down but
it was interesting the frat world i mean
yeah you've got you know your
stereotypes but
my sorority was literally like the best
i met the best [ __ ]
i met these women who are still so part
of my life and they were just like
you know we i don't know we just did
like dressed up and then we get drunk
and then do
philanthropic work like honestly and
truly it was like every other week we
had a new charity thing so i was like at
least we did some good you know
yeah yeah yeah and i'm like it was
culture shock though for sure yeah i'm
not trying to knock it all i think it
was also i think i was just like afraid
i think i just didn't know
anything about it right so like my best
friend went into it because his dad had
gone to school at university of
mississippi and so then
i just like would go and see like little
pieces of it and even though i was at
lsu for a couple years i just didn't get
too much into the greek stuff you know
yeah
and those guys were always such a
culture it was like if you weren't in it
you kind of weren't in
it right um well when i would meet
people out in la there's like
they would just be shocked that i was in
a sorority they're like yeah what's that
life like you know like they literally
were like did they beat you like what
happened
tell us about it yeah tell us about it
i'm like no it was actually fantastic we
would you know dress up and like go to
parties and
it just like live our life it was
fantastic yeah yeah i know everybody
wants
but when people are from the south i
mean listen there's great culture at all
these different schools
but i think specifically the south
everybody just thinks that like
you're just like yelling racist things
all day and like just
just being the worst terrific person you
can imagine yeah it gets the worst rap
man yeah especially out now like yeah
it's like oh my god you guys had fun
what was that like i'm so sorry you had
camaraderie and friends you're like
yeah [ __ ] you clark i did and i loved it
and it was fantastic
yeah oh you should be a nurse you should
be in our fraternity out here at ucla we
have uh we just got a new fish
yeah like the [ __ ] out of here it was i
remember going to some parties there and
it was
so lame it was just i'm sure it was
really really bad it would be like a lot
of people doing um
just bitcoin before it was a thing you
had to like talk about it yeah
it was like bitcoin rumors yeah that was
the night
yeah yeah so i went to ole miss you know
and then i went straight to new york and
i was like i'm gonna
do the comedy thing and now for most of
us you know learning a um
a second language in high school was uh
i mean it was just real challenging you
know you had to get out there and
[Music]
some people just wore kind of spanish
clothes and
got a d you know it just it was a real
it was hit or miss back then
you know but those times have changed
thanks to babel the number one selling
language
learning app there is an addictively fun
and easy way to learn a new language
so you're born you have one language in
you but you can get other ones
and that's how you do it with babel
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go so you don't have to be stuck
somewhere or
imprisoned or in quicksand or anything
you can do it
as you move babel designs their courses
with practical real world conversations
in mind real things you can learn
you know how do i get an omelette you
know where's my son
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian
and german right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription
you get an additional three months for
free that's six months for the price of
three
just go to babel b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
and use promo code theo that's right
you'll get three
additional months for free that's babel
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code t-h-e-o for an extra three months
free
babble language for life
ladies and gentlemen i'm here today by
uh
the grace of a higher power and also
because my mental health is well
some people have exquisite mental health
that's not me i have
well my mental health is well that's
where i'm hoping to be at
and something that helps me is therapy i
get therapy
you know i've had everything from
erectile dysfunction to fear of
lightning
so i get therapy and if there's
something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving
your goals then better help will assist
your needs and match you with your own
licensed
therapist there's no this isn't just
somebody who knows somebody
who knows somebody you know what i'm
saying this isn't like your aunt rhonda
has a friend
named mr jeremy and he's gonna help you
because you're struggling mentally
and he gonna help you over by his place
and it's
kind of creepy and [ __ ] it's not like
that better help is organized man it's a
real professional outfit
they're committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches
if you don't like the therapist they set
you with you can get a different one
you can do it on the phone you can do it
on facetime
but you know you don't have to go to a
private to a facility if it's going to
make you nervous or uncomfortable in
your area
visit betterhelp.com t-h-e-o
over a million people have taken charge
of their health
mentally with better help this podcast
is sponsored by better help
and this past weekend listeners get 10
percent off their first month
at betterhelp.com t-h-e-o if you need
assistance for your brain and your
feelings and your emotions
give it a try so did you find more
success than once you got out of kind of
the main
the not the mainstream but like the main
paths
of what we would expect
routes to find success because to me you
were extremely like captivating and
beautiful and uh and like um
original yeah and so those things to me
like as just a regular man
and also then as an inner entertainer
are very obvious
okay so it makes me wonder how uh
and maybe other executive stuff did see
that but
it makes me wonder like how you it
wouldn't be
such an easy choice to be like oh this
person
yes right well i basically i you know i
was doing the grind and you're having to
like
you know stroke the [ __ ] ego of these
people especially in that like ucb snl
world and i don't know i can't imagine
i was just kind of [ __ ] over it and
then you know the teachers are angry
people that didn't get where they wanted
to go and then everybody in my classes
like even in the early stages in new
york they all have these like creative
writing degrees from harvard and i would
show up in my hoops and animal print
and like a full face of makeup just like
what's up y'all let's [ __ ] try to
quit cigarettes
yeah yeah yeah i would have like a coors
light in my purse and just like you know
smoke a menthol and like chill and it
was so weird it was like
and i hate to like say this but like as
a woman in that world you had to like
not you know you just had to like play
games and i didn't want to [ __ ] deal
with it now who was making you play
with was it men doing that or was it
also because women get weird in that
kind of [ __ ]
i find yeah or what was it sorry you
ain't i just wanted to authentically be
myself i think i was trying to fit a
different mold and of course i just love
doing the characters
and and like wearing a wig and being the
ugliest version of myself possible and
just like tapping into these like weird
isms that i find in these characters
just brings me so much joy like that's
truly when i come alive
um and so i just was like [ __ ] this i'm
gonna pave my own way
and really and truly when i was in l.a i
was having a great time but again i go
on these commercial auditions listen i
went on an audition this is just so la
where the breakdown said morbidly obese
but beautiful
morbidly obese and i literally call my
age and i'm like listen i'm a thick girl
i got a thick neck and ankles you know
i've got the
shoulders of an offensive lineman like
it is what it is but i was like this is
the breakdown like this
is the the this is the mold that i fit
in l.a
and mortally is death literally dear
death one foot in the grave
yeah you're like my 600 pound life stuck
in a couch you have like
you're just eating pork chops you know
what i mean i was like i got a soul
cycle every now and then right now
um i sweat yeah when i'm not just like
sitting
alone um yeah yeah so i just was just
like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
um yeah that that kind of stuff is such
a grind
the commercial grind oh god i don't
think people understand like you drive
across town
and there's no hollywood yeah to north
hollywood to santa monica
sometimes the auditions would be in
montpelier vermont
they aren't anywhere near where you live
yeah they're like can you go up to
carmel it's an eight-hour drive
on a friday at five and then you go in
there and they
i literally like i was just done with
commercials when i went and they're like
here's the thing we know you're so funny
and you're so perfect for this they're
definitely going a different route we're
thinking like more
asian older man but we're so glad you
came here and i'm like listen i'm here
for the diversity i'm so glad we're
being progressive
but you just wasted my time driving
eight hours to carmel california and
they don't care and they're like look we
need you to go shave your head in your
car
right now and convert to a japanese
judaism and come back in here
exactly yeah like can you speak mandarin
and do you know how to knit you're like
no the [ __ ] i don't but i would fake it
till i make it
you know and probably offend everyone in
there but i was like i'm so desperate
for this [ __ ] job right now we need
to get your cloud up a little bit do you
mind going outside just using a racial
slur in the street for a few minutes
okay we need you to at least we need 20
000 more followers i don't care if
they're angry or not
exactly for this non-union commercial
that's going to pay you 14
in a subway sandwich and you're like
[ __ ] me but yeah so i after i
so i basically had to pick up my life
and move back to atlanta i was like it's
just gonna be temporary like i'm just
gonna go help the family out
and then when i started just living my
life authentically especially through
instagram because i
it's almost like a reality show every
day i mean i'm just uploading
stream of consciousness consciousness
what comes to my mind and then
all these women were just like thank you
for talking about this oh my god i
connect with this
and then i was able to start touring and
it was just insane i was like [ __ ] it i
built it on my own like
[ __ ] la you know i have to go back to la
like next week now
but the thing is when you leave la
that's when they want you yeah but if
you have
a p.o box or an address in los angeles
you
the phone never rings but as soon as you
leave they're like now you're hot and
fresh
we want this thing yeah this blood
diamond that's exactly that's what they
call us you know once you're out of la
they call you blood diamonds
yeah like oh how did we get that yeah
sierra leone blood diamond
how do we get that rare ivory you know
how do we get the ivory with the uh cane
sauce on the side of it you know
[ __ ] i love cane sauce yeah you know
i've never been
really like i've never been like really
southern i don't feel like
i'm sorry come again you do you think i
feel like i seem like a southern person
yes theo really yes have you taken a
look in the mirror today you have a
[ __ ]
mullet you have a tight fade and a
mullet
and you're from louisiana yes i guess so
yeah i don't know i just have never
really identified
as that well see maybe i don't know
maybe i'm projecting because i don't
feel southern
no it's okay no no it's i think do i
come off the southern
yes but then also the more i kind of
see what's going on i feel like you come
off all well here's what happens
sometimes in new orleans people also
come off as new jersey so you sometimes
there's some close stitching there i
hear that between like different styles
like
i don't think you come off as like
southern georgia which is where things
can get really southern you know daddy
yeah got a geese you know like it can
get [ __ ] a little
get a little weird you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that i don't know
i know how to put it on right and you
don't come off as uneducated so it's not
that
that redneck that kind of that thing
right you know like i never was into
that
uh or felt like that growing up um yeah
so i guess
uh but now do you find in the business
that they try and put you in that box
oh yes yeah and i will i won't honor any
of it the only southern thing that i've
even done
is when uh me and chelsea lin did though
we did a live show around the holidays
and i adore her and it was fun oh she's
so much fun it was hard to do but it was
a lot of fun
but that was like the most kind of
because she's not
she does like i don't know her character
or
you know tammy's
she's more she because chelsea's from
oklahoma so she's more just kind of
rural right is it redneck kirk i don't
know
i mean it's trailer trash tammy right
right but trailer
right but it's not redneck tammy right
like that's right it's working really
yeah we're really like peeling back the
layers
yeah she's just i think trailer trash
tammy here's the thing all of her
characters are like
very confident people and that's there's
always but that's a southern thing
southerners are confident it doesn't
matter like even at my lowest moment
like anxiety through the roof i'm like i
got this
like my daddy told me i got this i
[ __ ] got this and i'm from atlanta
like you said i'm not from like making
georgia
right but there's something about like
that southern inside of you where it's
just like i'm gonna [ __ ] do this like
watch out daddy told me yes so i'm doing
it
i do say daddy there diddy diddy hey
recipes yeah i don't think i ever had
that then i think i got to the lowest
point i was like i'm not gonna make it
who's coming with me right right right
and a lot of people were like i'm not
gonna make it either
i got a shotgun that's why i kind of
feel like
my group my like you know i feel like
it's sort of this
i don't know i honestly do not know who
my supporters are sometimes like i don't
know if supporters but like
i don't really know who's on my team
because it's not like redneck people
right no i think i i know your supports
well i'm one of them
but like i know that i know that dude
you know
it's a riley you know riley how are you
today
i feel like i'm in the presence of just
like barbra streisand
i adore you riley japanese greatness
right right there that's right
are you japanese riley i am yeah yeah
how's church it's it's pretty great
great i love that for you you're a man
of god i'm a woman of the lord so
that's why he just opened the door
earlier tonight we just connected i felt
the holy spirit
i could see that i felt it yeah and
riley last year got his first
kiss actually oh hell yeah hell yeah how
was it tongue
yeah oh yeah it was pretty great yes
yes yes cleaning the palette baby with
that freaking little ginger snap there
you go
now riley i'm a great matchmaker that's
just like one of my talents so if you
if you tell me like what you like i mean
you can be very specific with it if
you're like
i want her to have green eyes and you
know be into anime and
you know love chipotle like i will find
her so don't ever
you feel like you can ask me i will find
you doctor you saw us they call him dr
suss oh hell yeah yeah we're talking
about
green green eyes and breasts what uh
what do you like riley honestly if you
are looking for a woman i think
heather's very serious about that damn
that she would consider helping you out
brother
um yeah i mean i'm uh i'm more of the uh
i don't i don't i'm i'm honestly open to
anything not not anything anything but
like
um i mean like give us one
one detail yeah give us a neat deal like
you talking so are we talking five to
six feet what are we talking about yeah
cool um honestly as tall as you want um
like six four i mean you know do you
want to be cuddled at night like
you got just give me specifics how do
you want to feel about a day okay i like
being cuddled
okay great all right so a larger woman
okay larger woman fantastic um
i mean i'd like to cuddle her as well so
maybe she has one short leg one long leg
yeah
you want to backpack it huh yeah exactly
um
yeah um let's see what's fantastic
that's all i need
right there i got it and it's about what
you get out of them it's
uh yeah yeah you know it's a it's a
waiting game okay
give me a blog it's a game show you say
give me a blonde give me a blonde oh
okay okay there we go see i like that
and it's okay i think men now feel
intimidated like they can't say what
they want
but just be honest about it like i have
a very specific i want a woman yeah i
want a woman
that's fine i want somebody with a
vagina
you know yeah i prefer a good attitude
and that we can find that there's plenty
of women out there with vaginas and good
attitudes now riley because we haven't
even really gotten into this riley and i
know have you been uh
since the kiss have you been doing any
more dating or is it
uh not yet no okay um i like the
attitude though not yet yeah
not not yet but very optimistic you got
to speak it into existence
exactly you know put it on the vision
board i used to think that was such
[ __ ]
right and then i got high one like new
year's day and i made a vision board and
all this [ __ ] came true i was like
god damn okay so i think if you speak it
out into the universe you're just like i
want a blonde woman
who i can cuddle or maybe she cuddles me
you you'll see what happens
wow yeah you got it riley i mean look i
really believe
and is atlanta too far for you for a
woman not really do you have a mileage
uh do you have a
a distance no atlanta how far is that
land in far so
not far at all 34 minute flight
four-hour drive i got you
not bad but i got women all over like i
i have a posse of beautiful women in
nashville
yeah i got you okay i don't want to end
up in any sort of because
legally it's going to come back onto me
okay sorry
you know yeah how old are you riley i
need to make sure you're legal i'm i'm
22.
great yeah going on 23. i love yeah yeah
that's when somebody's young
they also tell you how old they're about
to be next
in 18 weeks i'll be 23. yeah yeah yeah
no look i would i i i i i would like it
you know i would like to find somebody
um
i had a girl just just kind of deserted
me recently but
she just left you in the dust huh she
just left you in the dust or ghosted you
or what
yeah she um well i was
living in iowa and i had two kids and
they were at the county fair
and she passed through town and that's
how we met i was taking
i was taking photos down by a bridge
okay and um
no that's bridges medicine okay okay
sorry
i just really like it but um what what
happened no yeah she just told me
it just wasn't for her man she told me
it wasn't for her so
how do you feel i was a little bummed
actually because i felt like i just
didn't share kind of i think i had some
more feelings and i didn't share them
and so i felt like i got kind of left
just like
she did it over text which was a little
bit of a i thought it wasn't cool
i hate that i don't even like to text
period like i am old school call me on a
home phone like i want to chit chat oh
yeah break in my [ __ ]
house yes yes break in my window breathe
over me in the middle of the night and
be like
yo we're meeting for lunch tomorrow like
that's the level of intrusion i want
club me and put me in your [ __ ]
step-dad's
acura trunk okay yes i want to
know that you care do you notice that
always it's like on amber alerts it's
always a [ __ ] like maroon acura
every [ __ ] time you know i don't know
what kind of like
uh marketing they're doing but every
time i get an amber alert it's like
maroon acura
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and then the
crazy part is with advertising
on the phones an hour later i'll get
accurate sale come on down to accurate
it's like this
is insane man [ __ ] no i'm not setting
myself up for
failure no yeah it's just crazy though
how you're out
the advertising but yeah i think look
there's probably good women out there
and you have a type do i have a type
really you know i think i'm kind of
surprised a little bit i like to have a
woman that maybe has a little bit of
probably
probably faith i think she likes to
laugh yeah she doesn't have to be like
uh
the funny person just to get jokes
though yeah
like just she just has to be able to
read you know what i mean yeah just like
like a basic sense of humor
yeah basic sense of humor whatever you
said faith like you want a woman who
believes in the lord
believes in some sort of faith it
doesn't have to be you know it doesn't
have to be christian
yeah but it has to be some sort of has
some relationship with a higher power or
wants to
yeah i don't want somebody just [ __ ]
hitchhiking the galaxy you know what i'm
saying like
like i need to know if there's a rapture
you're going somewhere
you know i just need to know that you
have a final destination it doesn't have
to be heaven it could be your own heaven
but i just need to know that like we
have something to look forward to
together yeah it could be somebody from
grubhub is going to come pick you up off
the counter and take you somewhere
that's fine okay okay but you got to
have you got to be a side item on some
deity's battleship yeah
i feel you there um so i think like that
maybe what else do i like
you know i want obviously something that
i'm attracted to um
are you more of like a blonde brunette
redhead like do you care at all i mean
and it's okay don't like me that much
they don't they do not and it's okay
and she can see it yeah i can see it and
it's fine
they do not like i don't know what it is
they've never
i've never really been their cup of tea
i think so you probably don't date
blonde zen or you you
know i've i've tried i've sent them dms
i don't
hear back from these women well any
women that are
you know uh followers of mine that are
listening yeah slide into thea's dms
and i really want like hot blondes like
i just i think you'd
look good with the blonde oh wow yeah
yeah
or if you're like kind of a cross-eyed
brunette also slide into yeah
so i feel like you'd also thrive with
somebody like a loose eye you know
yeah look i mean you can you can have
something that isn't exactly perfect
that's fine i'm not perfect
so i got a lot of loose pieces and um
so yeah but yeah i'm open to dating you
know i'm trying to be a little bit more
realistic about it and just like
actually not just dating whatever
you know i'm trying to actually you know
use my time wisely
but i feel like when you find the right
person you will know oh you do
you do you do when my husband we met i
mean when we were like 22. he walked
into a bar in new york and i literally
said to my friend tina who's here i said
holy [ __ ] i'm gonna marry him no she was
like but jeff like they were high school
friends
she was like my buddy jeff i was like oh
my god like this it was like a voice i
don't know where it came from
it was like deep in my taint and it just
came out and i was like that's
that's who i'm going to marry and sure
enough i mean 10 years later
we're married it took a while it's wild
it took a while it took a while yeah
it took a couple of uh took a couple of
yeah yeah
yeah but we got to we got to it yeah
yeah um
do you uh do you remember your first
kiss though growing up yes we talked
about this a lot and we've had a lot of
you know unique people sit here and talk
about it travis tritt
um who else came in here and talked
about that morgan wallin we talked about
um to me the first kiss like yeah i
remember my first like peck it was like
levi it was my boyfriend in kindergarten
but my first like adult kiss with tongue
i was 13. it was michael campbell shout
out to michael campbell if you're
listening
i was on a beach in destin on spring
break and i think he like it like it was
one of those things where you're like at
that weird age where everyone's like
so are we all gonna stand in a circle
tonight and like make out like it was
that
and he just tapped me on the shoulder he
turned me around and he shoved his face
in mine and it was just like
you know what i mean just like a yes
just an oral he was just almost like
mouthwash just really hitting
every spot in the mouth was it enjoyable
absolutely not cycle campbell they call
him
he's still yeah he still has whiplash
from it oh [ __ ] yeah he does
and once you stopped and his body
started spinning it was like something
on him was going to be rotary
100 and i remember turning around like
like it happened it was like 30 seconds
and then he like
walked away into the night in the sand i
was like was that a ghost
and i was in like a tank caney and i was
like [ __ ] yeah that girl features a
cheyenne song came on by dr brooks yeah
yeah yeah
and i just and there's like the thunder
rolls you know and then the lightning
strikes i was like
yeah hell yeah i just kissed michael
campbell yeah god michael campbell and
i'll say this that's a good name too
you got a damn good name right somebody
you hope you did something you know what
i'm saying i hope you did
something with yourself and you're not
just out there building fences right you
know
right yeah which is code word for being
in prison
being in prison uncle tom's building
fences you know
um i remember i remember now
you're really making me think about when
we would go to the beach and uh
and we would go and during the day we
would try to get liquor then we would
bury it in the sand
because like a sand dune yes because we
couldn't bring it back up to the hotel
room because the parents would see it
yeah and then we'd go out at night and
there used to be
boys and girls would just be walking up
and down the beach at night like
on the beach like right where you could
drown you know the freaking old natalie
holloway circuit you know
[ __ ] and you'd be out there just
trotting along yeah you would meet up
with somebody
and you might make out with them and you
were only 13 or 14.
i can't even believe we navigated it it
seems like
how how did we pull that off yeah i
remember got in so much trouble the
first time i took booze down i got a
thing of um
like seagram's the blue gin because i
thought it was gonna taste like gatorade
and that looked nice it looked so nice
and i bought it was kind of square a
little bit coming up
yeah it was like a sharp bottle you know
and i brought it down and we just like
buried it into sand dune my best friend
mary beth and i were like yeah we're
gonna chug it and i was like what the
[ __ ] is
gin you know my eyebrows just melted off
and i was like i didn't want this to
happen
my tank knees just falling off it was
yeah i was traumatized and my mom found
it under my bed when i got back from
like spring break and she was like
you're an alcoholic like i'm like mom i
barely drank it like i had like a sip of
it with gatorade and i threw up for two
hours so
yeah i barely drank it mm-hmm yeah and
the word
you would be you was trying to make out
with your mom like i don't remember like
the first couple of times you got drunk
it was like crazy [ __ ] you're like
that's
cute you know oh just be crushed it
would be great
like what and your parents and you guys
are at charlotte's and charlie's or
whatever
you got whoever the [ __ ] they were dude
they were gay men
and you guys were over there and your
parents like what in the hell is going
on
i studied abroad in italy and i
literally was so [ __ ] up the whole
time i was there and had the best time
but i thought i was going to like go to
italy and like
find like a hot italian man i hooked up
with like a romanian or croatian and
then i'm like
making out with this guy one night and
his name is fernando and we're talking
i'm like where are you from in italy
he's like i'm from cancun
i'm the only person who went to italy to
study abroad and hooked up with a
mexican guy
but his family owned carlos and
charlie's so that was the big deal he's
like come to cancun
my family owns carlos and charlie's i
was like hell yeah did you go like hell
yeah i did we're
we're still facebook friends you're
lying you know it's yeah yeah
and but i also i also don't 100
no i know for a fact his family did not
own carlos and charlie's because i got
there and like we had to wait in line
it's like goddammit fernando he was hot
though so
damn that's hilarious yeah that's great
do you remember were you guys pretty
well off growing up your parents have
some money
so my private school i did but
my i remember the beginning when my dad
was trying to build his business he
ended up being very successful but i
remember at the beginning my mom has
this like triggering moment where my my
dad essentially i guess like
did he make like the software for the
online credit report
so he was big in the mortgage business
and was like a computer nerd but we
started from nothing and i remember one
day we were at the grocery store and i
said mom we can't get that it's like ice
cream i was like we can't get it we
don't have a coupon
my mom said she went home that day was
like you better [ __ ] make this
business work
because these kids are like really like
shaming me in a kroger
um but yeah i mean when by the time i
graduated high school dad had sold his
company and he did well
so yeah yeah but i had this like great
southern father and
who was just like so i mean he had this
like deep southern voice
and he was like baby girl you can do
anything you're a goddamn mcmahon like
go for it like he loved being a girl dad
even though he was like this larger life
larger than life character he looked
exactly like
uncle phil from the fresh prince of
bel-air but white so imagine white uncle
phil that is literally my father i love
that mm-hmm
i love that man uh i
um and he died of cancer what kind of
cancer did he get pancreatic oh
once it gets down there oh you're [ __ ]
yeah and it was crazy from the day of
diagnosis of the day of death it was one
week
you're lying i swear to god he was gonna
have a [ __ ] heart attack and waffle
house he went to waffle house every day
he had his own booth like they have a
booth with a plaque on it where my dad
used to go
so he was really yeah i mean i thought
for sure if somebody called me and
they're like he just dropped dead in a
chick-fil-a i'd be like that's on
brandon that's on brand
um but yeah he had no idea and so we
went to the hospital and they're like
yeah he's got
you know he's i'll be lucky to make it
through the night and we got him to md
anderson in houston and then it was like
a week later
so it's also weird because when you talk
to other people about cancer they're
like yeah my mom struggled with chemo
for three years i'm like we had a
[ __ ] week
like i still went through it and saw it
but it wasn't i didn't have the same
experience as everybody else right
it was insane yeah yeah it was very
quick if you get pancreatic cancer but
then you have like that one [ __ ] we
had this real dick in our neighborhood
and he's had pancreatic cancer stage
four for like 13 years he's still
kicking it
but i'm like if you survive it you're
you're an [ __ ] like
if you're still on this earth i think
god either wants you to learn something
teach somebody something or you still
have something left to do i was like my
dad peaked
that's the way i have to like
rationalize it he was such a great guy
he had the successful company
he [ __ ] did it he peaked so once you
peek you're done like lights out
yeah you're you're gonna die yeah so if
you start to feel yourself peeking man
you better get hungry and figure it out
get real [ __ ] lazy
and make sure your will and estate is
you know yeah in the right thing
that's a good point actually it is a
scary feeling to feel like what else do
i need to do or what else am i supposed
to do yeah it's also
a nice feeling to think like what else
am i what is
what other purpose do i have and to find
some other purpose right i think that's
where i've been at recently just real
recently just trying to figure out like
find some more purpose for myself that's
not involved in me like that's one thing
a side effect of doing our jobs these
days
is it's a lot of me yeah and it's a lot
of me and it's a lot of like
do you know you're the product kind of
in a way and so it's a lot of me and
it's like god
yeah so damn myself self-loathing too
yeah i'm so [ __ ] sick of myself yeah
and then i had these moments where like
i never had anxiety before and i've
recently like been getting super [ __ ]
anxious
it's like almost like a manifestation
through my body where i'm like my head's
like i'm just like what the [ __ ] is
happening and i'm like i gotta get over
myself and then i'm like
you know it's like just stay [ __ ]
humble and not that i'm not but it's
like you're like why am i feeling this
anxiety like i know what i'm doing
i know what i'm here for but it's like
trying to find that bigger purpose
like maybe maybe it's the lord telling
me like slow your [ __ ] role do
something else for somebody
you know yeah yeah i think well that's
what they say sometimes yeah like um
that i'll find if i find yeah other
stuff to do for if i find stuff
if i make my focus other people right
then i'll find more joy
you know but yeah it's interesting man
because you start to become
that it's a lot about you because you're
the product and you're the only one
doing and you're also you're the
production company you're the
there's so many little things that you
are and it's like and then also we
you you made it work that way so it's
hard to
it's hard to delegate i don't know how
to tell anybody to do anything my entire
family
is like you need to hire someone but i'm
like when you've been hustling and on
the grind it's like i just know how to
do it
and that's another thing pisces we're
not great at delegating like i'm like if
i don't do it for my no we're not
we're terrible at it i mean you got a
good crew here and you got riley you got
to write this down
yeah i got you i got you um but yeah
it's it's really hard to just like let
go of the reins and be like okay i trust
somebody else because
when you're like do we sleep on our side
or not do we sleep on our back or
something no we sleep on our tummy
you sleep face down or on your side
i've been doing like kind of this almost
45 degree angle thing i got to figure it
out
okay we sleep on our tummy we do sleep
on our tummy i'm like face down
yeah okay yeah we're getting our lives
together
because i don't know a lot of this and i
think this is one thing where men and
women we don't know what's going on
right in the stars so we're out there
hooking you know like we think
everything's a little dipper
you know and we're like oh that's a
little different you know
yeah i mean i really had to have these
moments like after coming off the road
and like basically sitting at home for
20 20 i'm like [ __ ] i've had time to
like
be in the quiet and reflect and i
realize i only thrive in chaos
like when i'm on the road when i'm out
auditioning when i'm on 65 flights
in a month that's where i do well when i
have time to kind of sit alone in my own
thoughts
i'm like this is a scary place to be
yeah and it's not that i'm like you know
not in tune with who i am i think you
have to be to do comedy but there's just
moments like i don't do well in silence
maybe i'm [ __ ] codependent of [ __ ] i
don't know what it is but i need to have
like the noise around me
i'm also freezing my eggs right now so
i'm on a lot of hormones so i'm just
like
literally i'm sweating through
everything i have on right now and i
think that's also why my anxiety is bad
but
it's a [ __ ] wild ride frozen eggs
baby yeah i like that
yeah but they basically like i have to
put testosterone gel all over my
shoulders at night yeah
i already i'm built like a water buffalo
look i don't know i wouldn't say that i
built like a conestoga wagon i know that
i'm built like
yes pull up a gingerbread man this is
exactly what i'm like ladies if anybody
wants some of this you know what i'm
saying i want you to know what you're
gonna get yeah yeah yeah
full throttle we're going no frosting
okay we're going no frosting though
ladies
but pull up the water buffalo too yeah
water buffalo and gingerbread man please
can we get two images riley whenever you
get a chance
you know the brain is one of the biggest
organs in the body
and i made that up but that could be
true
you know these days you don't know
what's true man there's so much stuff
rattling around in your head facts
different things
vitamins um
scenes from old movies war reenactment
all kind of stuff
that's why you need to create some
headspace
wouldn't it be great if there were a
pocket-sized god that helped you sleep
and focus and act and be better
well if you have 10 minutes a day
headspace can change
your life it's that daily dose of
mindfulness that peace that you
taken taking you back from the greedy
vacuum
of the world headspace is one of the
only meditation apps advancing the field
of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated
research it's in bootleg research
that's right headspace is backed by 25
published studies
on its benefits six hundred thousand
five star reviews and over sixty million
downloads
you deserve to feel happier and
headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com t-h-e-o
that's headspace.com t-h-e-o
for a one-month free trial with access
to headspaces full library of
meditations for every situation
if you've been in a car accident or
you're just waiting for something
if your husband or wife left you
whatever it is you need to get away from
or have a little bit of peace from or if
it's just a long day
headspace can help you headspace.com
theo for one free month um
yeah it's interesting as you start to
like kind of know what you are and
what's going on yeah
but i can't imagine you know women you
guys get so when they do the eggs what
do they do take me through the egg hunt
it is such a wild ride and
can anybody do it or you have to be
chosen no no anybody can do it as long
as you have eggs
so you might actually have a couple eggs
i don't know you could look into it ah
dude i feel like a little bit of a [ __ ]
brother between us man between us now
that one looks a little too
i don't want to say that one i need one
a little bit lighter tone that one looks
a little bit argentinian for me
no not the water buffalo gingerbread man
yeah
okay i could see this do you have like
thick hands though no you've got a nice
underhand arms only have medium length
arms there we go let's go that happy go
lucky guy right there
there we go oh yeah and even the one
that's kind of running away at the
bottom that's me yeah
pisces running away from our problems
yeah that's right right there
now hit the water buffalo that's me to a
t a solid slender ankle
you know what i mean yeah great ankles
but just
really i mean it's just all the powers
right here make a sock out of my
freaking wiener that thing looks nice
bro
oh how's that little baby right there
yeah yeah yeah yeah god
so that's where i'm at but yeah i have
to put testosterone gel and then
like take estrogen pills so i'm just
spiraling like i don't know what the
[ __ ] happening
and where do you eat it do you just when
you guys for all summer you're in that
field or what do you guys do
yeah we just hang out in the field and
then roll around in testosterone and
grass
yeah yeah um we actually eat i mean we
you know we graze if you will oh i love
that we graze a little bit then we also
smoke a lot of menthols
okay yeah yeah yeah there we go
that's what i'm talking about
testosterone a little glaze in the grass
and then a lot of menthols these eggs
are
lightly charred huh yeah dude now that
you date a lot of brothers growing up
because i feel like it you seem like
and people must say this all the time
you kind of that brother bait did you
drive a honda civic and date a lot of
brothers i did not drive a honda civic
um i drove an old bmw but
so the i would say like if jeff got hit
by i have a very distinct type and it's
literally like
my father okay i like i consider like
identify as a lumber sexual
i like men in like plaid shirts with
chest hair and beards and like medium
penises like that is to me
okay that's that's my type okay um but
but the men who hit on me and slide my
dms the most
are urban gentlemen for sure i had a man
after a show in atlanta one time he came
up to me he's like
damn girl never lose your groceries
and i was like i mean i'm so sorry i
have no i literally was stumped and i
was like i'm so sorry sir what and he's
like
you know girl y'all melons and then just
then they just walked away and i was
like i don't know what just happened but
yeah
i'm kind of turned on right now yeah
black men also i think
they just have a level of they can i
think [ __ ] at a different
level i feel like i don't know
that yes yes yeah i don't know i i um my
last couple boyfriends were not
black but yes those are the men who
here's the thing i think because
they're just they're excited they're
like excited ready to do
they're like fun but they also like
really confident women
and and i think that's what it is like
we look at black women they're always
just like
owning themselves in their body so
comfortable like what do white women
have we have like gwyneth paltrow
telling us we have to do a [ __ ]
cleanse and put crystals up our vagina
all the time yeah
so i think i'm i kind of carry that
southern big hair big tits like let's
[ __ ] go
you know um energy how many people think
you're that lady
who married the football player's wife
do you right
you're gonna be a little bit more
specific the lady who married the lady
they had a reality show for a while on
bravo do people ever think you're that
lady
oh kim zolciak yes oh yeah okay
so my mom went up to her to publix one
time because i thought he was you
yeah yes my mom went up to her and was
like kim my daughter looks just like you
and then
showed her a photo of me and kim was not
happy with it but i'm like
kim come on girl like you would like you
know an extra 20 pounds but yes i do get
told i look like kim all the time oh
that's funny i get a lot of random stuff
um kim looked all different i mean i
haven't seen her in years or anything i
just remember they used to have a show
that she was on
yeah don't be tardy for the party and it
was uh because her husband played
at atlanta football and i'm a saints fan
so we would see
david play each other but i get uh anna
nicole smith a lot oh yeah yeah the
deceased yeah
deceased rest in peace but i get her
like when she was having a good day
i used to work at this gym in l.a and
this old guy named moses would come in
all the [ __ ] time and he would just
scream
anna nicole you're here and i'd be like
god damn it moses
like i know you're in a knee brace and
you're here to exercise but i want to
[ __ ] take you out by the knees like i
don't need you
and then everybody would kind of turn
and look at the counter and they'd be
like oh she is anna nicole and i'm like
god damn it
yeah yeah yeah yeah i wonder what
musical we would be in
sound of music is good it's a good one
yeah
i mean we're not hitting hamilton you
know what i mean i just don't think we
have
the diversity or the talent for it so i
think i
yeah i don't know and i don't like those
sh i think a lot of the uniforms they
were on a ship or something i don't like
a lot of that
i feel you i feel you then i mean what
else could you do we could do like dirty
dancing
oh yeah oh hell yeah hell yeah we could
have a moment in dirty dancing again we
would have no pants on
no no no no no no yeah exactly
just remember you're the one
thank you that song you don't talk about
yeah okay but then i would pick you
because i keep singing it and you're
seeming like you don't know what i'm
talking about and it's making me
nervous
never feel this way
no i know it i know i was letting you
know a wheelchair i gotta be in a
wheelchair
and in the end i just go off a little
ramp and then i'm at the bottom and you
crush me
but we figured out where like obviously
it's like stage combat where i don't
actually get hurt but that's the new
twist that you end up
killing me
[Music]
yes i love that they did a fundraiser
volleyball game
and it rained but people still came and
gave money and somebody got electrocuted
because they always had a band there and
that guy died but it wasn't about him
it wasn't it's never about him and
everyone's like hey you know what dylan
go [ __ ] yourself you always try and make
it about you
because he's a taurus and that's how
that works he is he's a taurus dude
he's a tourist but he ain't no freaking
bull like no he ain't a water buffalo no
he ain't
god it's like looking in the mirror oh
oh really i just don't i mean i
understand the relationship to i
understand
seeing an object pull up conestoga wagon
if you will
please raleigh
uh i couldn't [ __ ] tell you
let me let's go on record first time an
asian guy has asked
me how to spell something and no offense
riley i'm not
not assuming you're asian but
connoisseur wagon
we expect it better yeah how about this
dude
[ __ ] guess bro you know what i'm
saying
just type in wagon
let's see you spell it out i actually
want to see this go on
because the spelling bee at our school
and shout out this girl helena and they
called her big helena
oh she was pregnant that's why she was
big
and people were still like you're fat
and she's like i have a black baby in me
you know it was like kind of
but i'm about to [ __ ] crush this
spelling bee suck a dick
yeah she won the spelling bee in fifth
grade
pregnancia okay
women can do anything i'm telling you
thank you and we can't
thank you look at the statue of liberty
okay that's what that [ __ ] did you know
she's in heels and she's been standing
up that long she's been doing it
crushing
god uh this is a conestoga that's how
i'm built yes
hold on let me take a look at you let me
take a look at the wagon
100 that i've actually never seen
something more accurate
thank you yep the neck is right yeah
limited neck now
i can see you know i'll look around but
it's it's a lot of it's for show
yeah you're self-aware that's another
thing about being a pisces you're
self-aware
self-aware too self-aware and that's why
we get anxiety yeah
i think no i think you might be right
god i wish i freaking knew you more
because i just need a lot of this
information i got you i i will literally
help you i'll find you love
i'll do your taxes not well but i will
do them oh yeah yeah
um and yeah i'll find you love and help
you fix your life
okay that's but that's also another
thing i like to kind of help and fix
people
like i love a [ __ ] project yeah i
love a project oh dang
oh yeah yeah yeah a fixer-upper let's
go um
are you touring what are you going to be
doing so i kind of did what you did i
did a bunch of the live shows here's my
thing my audience gets really [ __ ]
rowdy
like originally they were like let's do
some of these drive-in shows but i'm
like
i've had to call an ambulance multiple
times for these drunk women
so i said the last thing we want to do
is have a drive-in show where then
there's like a 15-car pile up on the
highway
and my name's on the marquis so i was
like let's not do anything with vehicles
so you guys had a bad drive-in yeah yeah
no i just
i was like i'm not gonna do the drive-in
shows i know that's what everybody's
doing this summer so
i'm waiting i mean i had to put my tour
in hold so
i hope we're able to go out in the fall
i need to like pop in and start doing
some shows again but
no i haven't i haven't it's kind of
nerve-wracking i think now something
anxiety can come from that you're like
will people still come out they came out
before yeah
will they come out again and i i i fear
that i think everybody i think
a lot of people do in our business you
know you just don't know
you had things were going pretty
decently you don't know if people forget
about you
if they forgot you know like even though
there's proof that they didn't right
you still just don't know sometimes i
know my audience pretty well though i
mean everybody
love you i mean listen i have a very
very strong female audience and
and you know i am their white oprah and
i'm just so proud to have that role
um but i i know that these women i mean
they message me on the [ __ ] regular
they're like
i've got three kids i've been locked up
wrong with my [ __ ] husband
you know marcus like i'm gonna literally
murder the whole family you better be
performing this weekend
so i have a feeling it's going to be
like revenge travel like these women
when they're able when they're able to
be in a theater again they're going to
be
losing their [ __ ] [ __ ] so and i had a
wild
tour in 2019 where i was like god damn i
almost like felt a little self-conscious
i was like do i come off as like a
raging party or because i mean i drank
but nothing crazy
and these women would just be like
getting so [ __ ] up at the shows and i
had to be like hey guys i want you to
enjoy this and take something away from
the show so like
pump the brakes on the seltzers before
you get here
um but i think it's gonna get even
wilder like i think i'm gonna have to
just do some crazy shows right out of
the gate and then we can get back to
like
trying to be a professional you know
what i mean yeah that's a good point you
know i stopped in the comedy club last
night and um
and half the crowd i felt like was just
wanting to be out yeah they just want to
be out somewhere
if it's a woman or a man whoever has
come they're bringing their they've
wheeled their partner out yeah you know
the partner does not want to be there
the partner wants to be doing something
else they just got into like chess.com
or some [ __ ]
that eventually will lead them out of
the marriage yes because they saw the
queen's gambit now they're like oh yeah
i'm gonna be a [ __ ] chess tycoon
you're like
no you're not you're 20 years behind
yeah so i think a lot of people are just
wanting to be out right now yeah i mean
i'm starting to get that itch i mean
other than fact that i'm sweating
because i'm on a lot of hormones right
now but yeah i'm starting to get that
itch where i just need it's a revenge
travel like i'm ready to go
i had coveted i'm like i've got the
antibodies let's roll you know
um are you hot on your heart and took
the ac on oh i'm [ __ ] melting but
again it's because i'm on testosterone
is it i was on some a little bit i got
off of it but will you
do you mind cutting the uh air
conditioner on it's right outside of the
door yeah oh i didn't know if you could
have
it oh thank god crazy i'm [ __ ]
melting i've drank like
already this water i'm hitting a
smoothie it's been a while yeah well you
look nice though i don't see any sweat
on your head or anything
well i'm just i feel like the pants are
getting you know what i mean just i mean
when you have big tits though it just it
all it captures right around your heart
which you know that's why i have
[ __ ] hot flashes all the time that's
the other thing performing
i'm a very physical comedian and i get
off stage and then i do these meet and
greets and i have to like
change clothes and i don't sweat in
normal life i mean it's amped up
obviously because i'm on
testosterone gel but yeah i want to get
on i remember getting uh
i would get sweaty on stage and i
remember yeah i never had any tits like
that i had decent
i used to do steroids and i had some
pretty good tips for a little bit but
that was in college you know
mm-hmm and they were just you know chest
more
yeah i mean i feel like i'm on roids
right now like i literally called my
doctor before i came in
i've only been on these for a week but
you basically have to do this [ __ ] we
have to like prep your body
so you can grow a ton of eggs oh really
and then they go in and they try and
take as many eggs as possible
no way and it's a really weird feeling
like yeah it's almost like angry birds
yeah no it's literally angry birds
and it's the weirdest feeling because
most people they like take their eggs
and then they're immediately like trying
to
get pregnant but i've got to go finish
tours and like my career is just now in
this place where i'm like
okay i but my daughter's like you need
to try and get these out while you can
because in two years it might be hard to
get pregnant
so i'm doing all this [ __ ] to make your
body think that you're pregnant to
prepare
to then not have somebody like hand you
a baby it's the weirdest thing
so it's a real big emotional i mean
obviously you're a hormonal roller
coaster
but i'm just like about to have to start
shots in like a week like what
it's just the most outer body feeling do
they give you a prac like a
like a baby to carry around just like a
cabbage patch dog to take the
edge off um you know they can and
actually i think i should probably
request that i don't know why i didn't
ask for that in the beginning
yeah you get like a little papoose with
the baby and it's really just to see
like
if you are suitable to be a parent yeah
to get an attempt at least something to
keep under your arm for an hour
you know what i'm saying just something
to take that little grit out of you yeah
and i asked my my husband um i said you
know like ideally when would you want to
have kids
he was it's just such a typical dude
answer he's like i don't know like five
to seven years
like the clock is ticking bro like i
don't have that he's like let's start in
like seven years i'm like
i'll be like well into my 40s it's not
going to happen
um after illinois wins you know like uh
we don't know when that's gonna
be oh everything's around penn state you
know
he's just like yeah when penn state like
wins a championship and so i'm like
yeah good luck to you when they stop
molesting people yeah then maybe
but yeah they're in the wrong business
no people so many people have been
molested and called into this show so
it's totally
yeah that's nothing crazy yeah um what
else do we want to cover here let's
let's bring up another question that
came in uh from someone that loves you
and uh
and we'll see what we can do here
actually you know what i want to get to
real quick
let's bring up that video of um we do
something on here where we do something
fun nice for single moms so we had
somebody who called in and submitted one
so let's get that video up real quick
if you don't mind riley mal oh
oh okay is your title nervous hey yo
it's cody from central pennsylvania
i wanted to nominate my co-worker kim as
a single mother
you know whenever we come back to our
office uh a bad day had a hard day
uh she's always a smiling face um cheers
us up
a great woman you know she's raised
a good daughter got a good head on her
shoulders
um you know she's trying to take care of
her mother
um commuting to take care of her mother
as well um
and it's just been a little tough lately
um figured i'd reach out
but um gang gang gang baby thanks for
the call let's call kim real quick and
we'll just
i love that you do this let's give her a
call yeah look it's
uh it's nice that people support man and
i remember my mom always just like i
just sometimes if she would have had
like a little extra cat just to do
something yeah just so she like a couple
of
hours you shouldn't have to think about
something you know like i feel like it
just would have helped her a lot
um but what do i know also let's see
let's call him up riley can you get that
lady on there kim is her name
yep he's on he's on by
oh god i cannot wait to set up riley i'm
so thrilled
yeah now that i want to see yeah you
know i'm sure i could eventually figure
out something if something real
you know positive comes across your desk
let me know can you switch to the camera
so they can see me or riley or there we
go
she's gonna think i'm a damn pedophile
hey kim
yes hey my name is theo i'm just uh i
guess i'm a stranger really but
um i am calling you a friend of yours
i work on a podcast i'm a podcast guy
and a friend of yours called who was the
guy who submitted the video riley can
you tell me
uh cody cody a man named cody that works
with you
reached out and he said because
sometimes we we
i was raised by a single mother
sometimes we do something nice for
single moms so he nominated you he just
said look
there's a lady that works with me and
sometimes i'm having a bad day or at
work we're having a bad day
and i see her and she always boosts my
spirits and she's been a great mom she
has a child and she's been taking care
of her mother
and it's just been a lot he said i've
noticed it might have been some extra
stress on her recently
so he just nominated you um
and we just do a thing where we just
just give you a little financial gift of
a thousand bucks and you can go do
something fun
and um and that's all it is so we just i
know it's a lot of me talking
immediately out of the gate and i just
wanted to uh
to just let you know why i'm calling so
you don't think i'm some kind of pervert
or something
[Laughter]
well thank you so much theo i really
appreciate that that is really awesome
uh cody is an awesome friend and
co-worker
and uh when he told me that he he did
this um i looked you up and i watched
one of your podcasts
um and enjoyed it very much so um
so this this is great in many ways
because he he opened my eyes to to you
and you're a funny guy so
and he said that you do great things for
people and
um just is wonderful well that's sweet
i'm gonna say that you know it's nothing
super big but
uh yeah sometimes it's nice to have a
little bit you know just something extra
to you
a little extra coin you go do something
you know do something take mom to the
skate park or something you know
um what does your mom enjoy doing do
y'all spend any time what's
what's the time like that you guys spend
together well um
unfortunately my mom is ill right now
um and i just saw her a couple days ago
for the first time in over a year
because of cove and um so she's
struggling
um i'm trying to to help her
i live two and a half hours away from
her so it's not easy to see her on a
regular basis
um so i'm just trying to help her
hopefully
move her closer to me i
and just take care of her um she's 71
um which is you know still fairly young
i think yeah but
oh yeah a lot of games of scrabble left
in that lady i think
yeah do you guys like to play a board
game or is there something you like to
do my mom and i like to play scrabble
sometimes
oh yeah well um not recently
um because i've been away from her for a
few years um
we used to go to uh concerts a lot oh
damn
oh yeah we've been to you know anything
from rock to country to
it's pretty much anything um so so that
was really big for us for many years
oh wow and we're we're big washington
football team fans oh wow that's
incredible
um well you know what also i think maybe
um
we'll have to send her some nice flowers
or something we'll grab her address from
you you know so we can just
you know and keep in touch and see if
there's some other way that we can help
out i don't know if i know anybody with
the washington football team
i'd say i'd get you some tickets over
there but i might though
i'm gonna have to ask around maybe we'll
see what we can do um
and we have heather mcmahon here today
too she's a comedian friend of mine
hello she might have some suggestions i
don't know what
what what what do you do with your mom
heather um
my mom's 73 and sassy i mean she loves
the home goods you know what i mean she
just likes to be bop around town
um yeah here's the thing we're gonna
figure out i'm gonna reach out to
whoever i need to we're gonna get you
some tickets so washington game
oh i mean i feel like i'm well
lubricated well connected we'll figure
it out
yeah yeah could your mom go to a game
you think possibly one day or what do
you think
um i'm hoping as of right now no
just because of her medical issues right
now but um i'm
i sure hope that we can in the future
okay so that that is a little iffy right
now but
um it would be great to take her to a
game
it's been uh almost 10 years since we've
been to a game
so oh dang well it's probably been that
long since the team's been decent too
so um probably a little over 20. okay
and you're still fans wow good on you
lifelong lifelong fan no matter how good
or bad
they do that's pretty cool yeah i i i
yeah you don't meet a mother daughter
uh football fan i haven't met it that
much i haven't i just want to say i
think it's so
fantastic that you're taking care of
your mom i moved back in with my mom and
my mom's 73 and just like the
these this time that you get uh with
your parents just like hold on to it
because it's
you know you can't get those years back
so you're doing the lord's work you
really are
well thank you that's why i want to move
her closer to me so i can see her on a
daily and weekly basis um it's it's
really really difficult to have her so
far away
and and i hadn't seen her in almost a
year and a half and it was just very
difficult
i'm an only child i have an only child
my mom's an only child so we have like
the world's smallest family
i think damn yeah and what what's the
biggest
thing preventing you from having her
close right now
um financial issues
yeah yeah um i i need to
figure out how to get her moved up here
um just moving costs
um and find a place that has some
assisted
she needs some assistance so um not
necessarily an assisted living place
but um day-to-day health to come in
yeah on earth moving's expensive and
help like
nursing is so expensive so i hear you
it's
we looked into it for a family friend i
was like i never realized how truly
expensive it is yeah to get an extra set
of hands
you know it's it yeah and if you go
through the government and stuff it's
hard to get that
it's all these so much documentation and
you can't have a job a lot of times if
you want to get help it's really
it's really tough you know what i want
to i want us to help out as much as we
can so i want to stay in touch and see
if there's some way that we can't find
some
um you know i don't want to promise
anything but just see if we can see what
the costs are in some of the longer term
kind of thing i know
uh when my mother's when her husband
when her second husband died one of her
biggest or as he got older one of the
tough things was my mother couldn't
claim any income because if she did she
couldn't get like
you know then she couldn't get
assistance and all this there's so much
rigmarole um
so anyway i bet your mom's so proud of
you though
she is she is very proud of me and and
i'm proud of her too
um you know she was a single mom and uh
it was tough and
and now i'm a single mom uh of five
years i guess it's been and uh
yeah it's tough but uh but we're very
very close
and would like to continue that as long
as possible
well we're gonna stay in touch and see
what we can do to try and help out and
uh and just thank you so much and
and um yeah just thanks for answering
the phone today yeah and just
it just puts us in a place of just
remembering uh that we're
you know that everybody's kind of
dealing with something whether it's big
or small sometimes and that um
it's nice to connect and think about
those things together right
right well i really appreciate your help
and your thoughtfulness it's really
awesome
um well these days it's really hard to
find
nice people that want to help out and um
i i greatly appreciate it
well that's sweet of you to say that and
yeah we're gonna stay in touch and see
what we can do to try and
i don't know i feel like we can be a
little more helpful though and so i just
want to see
let's let's see what we can do and uh
and thanks for your time today
and um i hope you guys have a nice day
over there
okay well thank you so much theo it's
really nice meeting you thanks so much
for your help oh you bet take care have
a good one
all right take care okay bye-bye bye-bye
so sweet yeah that's got to be tough
when your mom's far away huh yeah
especially if you want to go and it's
like if you're still working and then it
take that you got to get that extra time
to go do that i'll say
after like moving back in with my mom
now i've done it twice right right after
my dad died
i had like a period like i can't believe
i'm doing this and like i have a sister
and she's fantastic but her career was
she's an attorney and life was busy but
i like picked up and moved back home and
i was just so resentful for so many
reasons i was like mourning my the loss
of my father but also like my mom's
a young spirit like she can do stuff you
know it's not like i mean
god bless like she didn't need physical
help um but there were moments
now looking back i'm like i can never
get back back that time with my mom
and so my husband and i literally gave
up our apartment in new york and we've
moved back in
with my mom now and we're like taking
over our house and all this and and
jeff my husband is like so into it and
he loves it but i just like have so much
[ __ ] fun with my mom now
like she's just the best and i'm like
it's the best decision
most people are like you live with your
[ __ ] mom i'm like yeah yeah i do
you rage and it's amazing you know like
i'm like i've never had more fun in my
life i don't want to hang out with
anybody my own age
she's 73 doesn't look a day over 40 and
she's just savage
she is unreal and it's the best
i wonder if we had a show and it would
be like you and like
maybe you and your mom live together and
i'm like the brother that comes back and
lives with you guys
or something and you think i'm gonna
help but i don't help
yeah you just hang out in the basement
do bitcoin play fifa
uh-huh yeah yeah and i end up dating one
of your mom's friends
from the country club yes yes yes yes
and then like you you bring her home to
your basement yeah apartment
uh-huh uh-huh yeah it's not far off yeah
i like this
yeah but riley where do you fit in man
we don't we still don't have a lady for
you man
yeah man i mean
i think uh if if uh heather you know
helps out
with uh i got you i think you i think
you got me i got you when's your
birthday
july 14th so what are you a cancer yep
oh we're going to get along
cancer and pisces okay we're going to
get along i got you
ladies if you're listening and you like
a kid you're not it's a lot of sad men
who listen to this
no offense guys i got y'alls back fam
you feel me
baby there you go no joke
i'm sorry no no but i know they're sad
yeah i know they are i know they are i
can feel the energies just reads
really sad um and riley's giving me a
little i mean you're giving me
a little joy but mostly sadness
and i love that i mean i listen to this
podcast religiously so i live
for when you you know you just you give
like the least but i can get the most
from it yeah so i just need you to know
that
even though you're doing the least i'm
getting the most and that's
what it's really all about riley right
so i got you i will find you a woman
with green eyes and
maybe one leg maybe two legs you know
yeah maybe three nipples i don't know
but it's gonna get freaky
but i will make sure she's a woman of
the lord there you go yes i got you
amen i got you got us good all the time
and all the time god is good yeah there
you go right yeah yeah yeah yeah riley
mao
yeah yeah let's bring one more question
from one of those listeners and then i
think we'll probably be good for the day
great because i've sweat through
everything
it's kind of cute i think but oh oh that
is not one of my listeners
it could be it could be okay let's see
oh hey heather it's brent coming from
michigan and yeah heather i see you like
to travel a lot
have you ever had like a near-death
experience and if so where
and how did that go let us know okay
i love this the aggressive like what's
up it's a very michigan thing too
i think so you know what i mean just
like what is what is life
um near death experience uh let's see i
mean
dude yeah i almost died in baltimore i
don't know if you've been to baltimore
i have it's basically the black maine
and yeah it gets a little
it gets a little a little crazy people
had warned me i was there for a show
and people had warned me they're like
just wait till um you see somebody doing
like the heroine
yes and they're literally like zombies
walking out and i played this club that
was across from like one of the
scariest movies was it was it no sorry i
need to quit interrupting no no no no
you're right um no i'm not no i think it
was like
oh [ __ ] it was some i can't remember the
the place i remember
we rolled in we couldn't find food
anywhere yeah and we were saying like
they were like there's one street in
baltimore you can like stay in a hotel
there but you can get a sandwich here
everything was closed this wasn't during
covet this is
in 2019 i remember seeing during regular
time
like the subway was closed like a subway
sandwich was like i just need a [ __ ]
sandwich and then i came out and
everyone's doing the heroin lane oh yeah
and i'd never had a panic attack in my
life but for some reason like just the
energy of baltimore
i had a panic attack right before i went
out on stage and i had to start the show
and like work through it so i did have
that moment where i was like okay
i i just did a show through a panic
attack so i can do
anything like anything that gets thrown
at me i'm like i got this
yeah and then when we got back out of
the theater it was more people doing the
heroin lean i was like we got to get the
[ __ ] out of baltimore
i just i don't get it and people from
baltimore got really upset they're like
our town's great we've got crabs
like if that's the only thing you have
crabs and spirit airlines like i don't
know
what i just don't see the draw i really
don't
crabs are just suv shrimp brothers they
really are [ __ ]
this is a shrimp and armored truck
that's all it is bro i mean crabs are
great but
it's not y'all you know it's happening
under water you're not doing it i'd like
to see you do more above ground
yeah yeah i 100 at least dolphins come
out
they come out of the water that's all
they do hello pop
pop and pop out yeah i would love to see
a crab at least you know
give me something give me something yeah
but yeah baltimore's a wild place man
there's
i definitely i remember going there one
time and there was uh people
yeah kind of heroined out up top you
know just kind of wandering around and
ufc had just come there for the first
time people were going insane
she had people that were fighting each
other in the street and then you had
heroin people just kind of like
refereeing
there was a a third world i can't it's a
third it's a fifth it gets
yeah it's yeah it's like a two and a
half world i thought about getting into
the ufc stuff i know you're a big ufc
guy but i have
some of the female ufc uh fighters that
follow me and i just expected these
women to like come up they came to one
of my shows in atlantic city
and i just expected them to be like
ripped and they were like half my size
and i'm like you're in the [ __ ]
octagon
because like i feel like i'm built to
fight i'm a very like gentle person but
i'm just i'm very limber
like i got a high kick i'm strong you
know i feel like i would thrive in that
environment
but i don't know i know you're training
i could see i've been doing some
training yeah i like it i really like it
my
ribs got hurt i've fought in a lot of
the women in class uh i could see you
doing it yeah yeah
i could see any woman doing it it
definitely it's a confidence builder
and it's not about as much the fighting
when you're at the training it's just
more about like
learning how to like women will
definitely learn to defend themselves
and how to like that's what i want too
yeah a lot of them know how to like
you know break someone's nose if they
come up behind me out of valet
you know i just want to [ __ ] some [ __ ]
up oh yeah yeah preservation
yeah you could do that you'll be
preserved after a couple of classes
i think yeah yeah i really i really
enjoy it i think it's fun
um and a lot of the fighters are really
nice people um do you only fight people
in your weight class
you're supposed to i thought i had a
blind guy there
look it's really um i have a long way to
go
okay they have put me in blind females
and
most recently a blind gentleman yeah
albert oh sweet albert
well how'd it go uh he's [ __ ] good
yeah he's good man i think he used to do
gift wrapping or something like a macy's
so
he [ __ ] had me the best massage i've
ever had in my life was a blind man
yeah and he was like they you know they
warned me but this guy they're like
he'll change your life and you can feel
him feeling around the table and i'm
like yeah you lose one sense
you get a new sense in your hands i mean
it was incredible he knew the body
like no one's business i was like i
really kind of only want blind masseuses
from here on out yeah you know yeah i
think
eventually sight will become a thing of
the past um
but just in general just yeah i could
see it phasing out
yeah i could yeah my hearing's going for
sure yeah
who needs i mean i think i was having
skin starts
to feel really like archaic almost like
in the future it seems like we'll have
some sort of a dip or something people
will be in
like a paraffin wax that you just go in
and then that's all that's your new skin
something like doesn't it seem almost
our cake that we're still wearing our
old skin
it seems crazy that women are still
giving birth
with their actual body you know what i'm
saying something starts to seem a little
bit like
like you see somebody do it and you're
like oh this is going to become outdated
this seems almost oh i feel like an
alien right now putting all this [ __ ]
into my body and then i have to do the
shots and it's like
couldn't we have done this with like a
grapefruit like there's a lab somewhere
that could be growing this yeah
you know barbra streisand what she paid
a bunch of money and like cloned her dog
and i'm like yeah it was
only like actually twenty thousand
dollars when you think about it for like
cloning an animal
i'm like yeah let's why aren't we there
yet right maybe we are i don't know
they haven't called me they haven't i
don't get the email you know it'll
probably start you know
at a start abroad first i'm sure because
we haven't too many regulations
you know here you know it's tougher to
get things passed here we'd probably
have a lot different stuff you know
yeah but well i mean you know good old
us of a
remains to be seen it remains to be seen
a lot of things
uh heather man thanks so much for coming
in today thanks for having me yeah i
appreciate it and people can uh
check you out yeah check me out on
instagram yeah and uh
you can listen to my podcast the
absolutely not podcast absolutely
not not podcast and we'll put links to
all that right in the description and uh
yeah thanks so much for your time and
for coming in and for bringing your
childhood friend in
hey thanks for letting me sweat on your
couch this has been a real magical
afternoon
yeah we're gonna auction off that that
cushion actually yeah let's get weird
with it for all your sad
lonely male followers riley's probably
going to keep that in fact
no it'll smell like testosterone riley
ooh
really i actually feel like there's been
a little sexual energy between us
i really do i do i mean do you feel that
way oh yeah
okay good good riley is i mean all he
has is sexual energy
honestly radiates it radiates sexual
energy and i don't think you're living
your truth so i think
i'm gonna get you with a broad shoulder
then ankled
just big titty blonde girl who loves the
lord
you know he's in the youth about no not
youth sorry god no
no she's a youth group leader but she is
an adult
look let's be honest at some churches
she could be as long as she's kind of
like
as long as she's a pastor in training a
pit or whatever passer
yeah whatever it is you know but i see
it and i i
just asked one thing if i find you your
wife can i please officiate the wedding
sure hell yeah okay great
i love it look who knows what can happen
magic
it could be how magic starts uh heather
thanks so much for coming in
thanks for having me now i'm just
floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i
[Music]
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
[Music]
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want something